there's more to do with that than just  looks a lot that's toxic that's toxic  relationships for you yeah you know  honestly  um do you think like like a nine gives  it better than that seven because I  personally think sevens give it way  better than tonight  do they feel like they have to work  harder  I don't know what lines you get  maybe maybe I feel like the pretty you  are the less you kind of do in bed  because the ones that aren't as great as  the rest that they work they work it's  gym Antics we go into the night I think  it's more to do with how crazy she is is  it how crazy or how beautiful she is  that determined well that determines  what her passion yeah that's what they  usually say it's more to do with her  instability crazy in the real world is  linked to passionate in that world so  more to do with looks it's more  instability unstable women tend to be  more passionate